you
I wanted to talk to you about ten things
I've learned in my first year as a
public company CFO it's a big step up
from being a divisional CFO it's a
really interesting and fun job and I
think it's a an interesting day to
reflect on this on the day of the Enron
verdicts so it's a very important thing
to kind of think a little bit about what
you're doing and the message you're
carrying out to the financial community
and your shareholders so I'm going to
try to make this interesting and fun so
see how we do I want to talk about these
things things that I've learned were to
be prepared know who your bosses are and
what they want set a few goals but not
too many goals know what your
organization is about the good parts and
then the warts as well and play your
strengths the things that I came to the
job knowing were the balance sheet and
corporate development I've been an
assistant treasurer and head of
corporate development as Bob said at
PepsiCo where we were pretty well
trained I've put together a pretty good
team but what you have to do in this job
because you have a constant stream of
demands coming at you has learned to say
no you have to prioritize and focus and
learn to say no that's been important as
you may have noticed there are not a
million women CFOs these days and I've
found that the ladies room can actually
be a goldmine for intelligence and I'm
going to talk a little bit about that
and then there are just some days that
are bad days we've had a bit of a stock
price adjustment and not in the right
way at Moody's lately so I'm going to
talk about that and then on this day of
the Enron verdict I'm gonna talk a
little bit about how the tone at the top
really drives the culture of places
because it's very important to know now
on the be prepared front as bob was kind
enough to say I am a graduate of Lehigh
the 18th best undergraduate Business
School in the u.s. so Business Week has
just granted it as such and in fact a
woman named Alice gasped who was a
chemical engineering professor here has
just been named president of Lehigh
she's most recently Provost at MIT so
another in a list of women becoming
university presidents pretty interesting
so after I've made a bit of a detour
there to the army
I enrolled here in 1984 and was a member
of the quite successful class of 86 so
it is 20 years for me at this point so
professional experience is even more
helpful and as Bob said I did this thing
which had absolutely no bearing on
anything that I've done since but I did
have the choice of going to West Point
for the first class of women through
West Point or to Lehigh where my father
went and having decided that it was
countercultural enough to go through
ROTC had become an Army officer I chose
to do that and actually it was pretty
good leadership training so but a bit of
a difference untraditional kind of
background now many of the companies
that I work for an investment banking
I'm sad to say no longer exists this is
this is a bit a bit I guess humbling I
look for the logo for First Boston the
first Boston corporation had a big ship
its became part of Credit Suisse which
then decided last year to drop the old
first Boston name so I did Island gas
M&A there under Bruce Wasserstein and
Joe Perella but first Boston as we know
it is lost to the history books
similarly a banker's trust a company
which was bought by Deutsche Bank did
oil and gas M&A there as explaining to
some of the professors today that some
of the folks from Bankers Trust made
their way to Enron and a very
interesting story there Bankers Trust
was really in the forefront of doing
derivatives and not always in the most
constructive way but from Bankers Trust
I got recruited to PepsiCo and corporate
experience is really very useful perhaps
he's a great company and was a terrific
learning experience and is obviously
doing quite well so then from there I
went to a small consulting firm and then
I went to us trust working for Schwab as
Bob said and then I got this job so the
point of this is there's not a linear
path to where you're going to be in 20
years and if you think you can plan out
your life as to where you're going to
get to 20 years from now it's probably
not going to work exactly as you have it
planned out so leave yourselves open to
different experiences and you'll do fine
now balance the new model for women
professionals is you're supposed to have
a stay-at-home husband this is the new
thing you're supposed to have
husband who kind of takes care of
everything on the home front so you can
have a big job and I've failed at that
miserably because that guy on the upper
left there is my husband Victor Lopez
Balboa somebody here in this group
actually used to work for my husband at
Goldman Sachs he runs the fig group and
he has 270 employees and a
billion-dollar business so I've failed
on the stay-at-home spouse front the
other thing you're supposed to do is
have grown children now as you can see
from the picture here my children are
hardly grown they're now 14 10 7 & 4 so
it's a little hard to juggle all this
but it but it can be done and I'm sure
it is much easier if you have grown
children but we're not there yet so in
addition to being prepared another good
thing to be able to do is to know your
bosses and know what they want now in
the scheme of things in our public
company that's me way down there and
very important you know 20 billion
dollar company we have a very important
place in the capital markets so it's a
big job right we're very I'm very
important well actually not that's my
boss ray McDaniel who is chairman and
CEO of Moody's corporation great guy
forum a lawyer terrific boss and I feel
very fortunate to work for a guy like
Ray who's a high integrity guy but on
our board we have these seven exalted
people we have basil Anderson who was
the CFO of Campbell's and vice-chairman
of Staples a former CFO number one
Bob Glaber who runs the NASD a bald
kissed who used to run ing senator
Connie Mack Hank McConnell who has a PhD
from this institution and is now CEO of
Pfizer also was a CFO Nancy Newcombe who
ran risk at Citi and also was the CFO
and John wolf who just to make it really
really difficult used to serve on the
fast beat
so I had to interview with him and
answer accounting questions which was
actually quite interesting so you know
what do you think of Fez 133 well you
can't really answer that honestly
because it's a pretty difficult thing to
deal with but that's our board for
former CFOs
on most boards no one wants to be the
financial expert on this board everyone
except Connie Mack is a certified
financial expert so you have your board
one insider buy boss seven Outsiders
seven extraordinarily well-qualified out
sliders so those are the guys we work
for now this is a famous guy some of you
may know goldman sachs asset management
owns 7% of our firm so I kind of work
for Hank which is helpful because my
husband also works for Hank so we're
pretty tuned in to what Hank wants ken
feinberg Davis select investors they
also own 7% of our company so he's my
boss too and then last but not least we
work for God Warren Buffett on 16 and
1/2 percent of Moody's we're his third
largest holding Warren gives us very
specific exacting advice his advice the
spring when we wanted to go see him was
just don't do anything dumb so we worked
very hard to follow Warren's extremely
exacting advice and so Warren is
terrific he he doesn't bother us too
much and we continue to try not to do
anything dumb these guys at the top are
people that we have to talk to all the
time if you're a CFO you pay attention
to your shareholders if you don't your
career is going to be more limited we're
lucky to have a very strong group of
shareholders but a lot of consistency
50% of our holders are 10 very strong
institutions so that's good and we have
a very strong board advising us so you
can see my relative importance in this
entire group of bosses that I have so in
terms of setting goals and not too many
when I came in
Moody's has a small company that's
become a very big company and it's been
become very successful so we wanted to
get the team aligned around what we
should do really four things were trying
to do drive growth and profitability
support the line business put in place a
good control environment pretty
important if we're Moody's because we're
eight everybody else and if we screw it
up it's kind of a major problem and then
make it a great place to work we've
added the Human Resources team to the
finance team and so we've been able to
do that so we know what our goals are
and we try to keep them simple so my
staff of 200 can follow what we're
trying to do so the next thing I had to
do was learn the organization Moody's is
a rating agency some people think that's
actually very boring well it's not
boring because you sit at a very
important place in the capital markets
and as someone pointed out we rate 100
nations and we rate 11,000 companies
25,000 public issuers
seventy thousand structured finance
obligations and we do credit risk
quantitative analytics as you see at the
bottom so the opportunities to annoy
clients are just extraordinary in number
and scope so you have to be very careful
about dealing with your clients we spun
off from dun & bradstreet in 2000 along
with coach we were probably one of the
most successful spin offs in that year
so our cab market cap was 4.5 billion at
the spin it's now been up to 20 it's
back down to about 17 right now and we
were named one of the ten best men one
of the best managed companies and
business services during that time we
have 3,000 employees in 22 countries so
it's a big company
so that's the growth record I have to
make sure that you understand that this
is a log scale our previous CEO liked to
use this but we've only had a couple of
weak years there when the credit cycle
has been difficult but consistent
history of great revenue growth great
profit growth so the company is
terrifically strong it's a cash engine
our cash flow equals our operating
income we have 54 percent margins and
the business model is just extraordinary
so we're very lucky to be able to put up
numbers like this revenue distribution
by country we're 63% you ask the rest
international the international
businesses are growing faster structured
finance is really the exciting part of
what we do the corporate part of rating
companies about 20% of our revenue the
correct credit derivatives business the
yellow piece up there is just about the
same size so the structured business has
really become much bigger than the
fundamental business for us and it is a
much higher growth rate so that's what
we do and the real engine of the company
is the structured finance business we
have a lot of quat's we have a lot of
mathematicians and lawyers and people
who look at all different types of
things that you can rate in the
structured finance area in 1992 those
were some of them and in 2006 those are
some more of them I was telling Jim this
morning that my favorite particular
class of securitized things are cosmetic
surgery receivables I'm not sure that's
a burgeoning asset class but it is one
that exists so if you look at this list
which you can't see on purpose it's a
pretty interesting list but we rate a
lot of very strange things
the stock performance of the company
with all that has been pretty good I'll
get to the recent past but about the
time here that I was asked to make this
presentation our stock price was right
about there so be careful what you wish
for in terms of challenges this is a
very interesting slide this slide was in
our investor presentation and if you
look at the revenue growth there pretty
spectacular revenue growth the PP&E
there though which our previous chairman
used to say is commendable because of
its extraordinary flatness it kind of
looks like New Jersey you know it's just
really flat perhaps we have to look a
little bit about how much we're
investing in this business which is
growing so rapidly so that's one of the
things that I have to wrestle with but
you have to realize what's good and
what's bad about the company that you're
you're working in and that's a challenge
that we face so in terms of when I got
this job what did I do the balance sheet
last June we had a spectacular amount of
cash on the balance sheet almost a
billion dollars for those of you who are
going to work at hedge funds and I would
expect that's most of you in this
audience hedge funds don't like having a
lot of cash on the balance sheet they
think it's an underused
asset and it tends to attract them so
we've been working on working down our
cash balance was it six hundred and five
million at the end of March but
something that we're working on
redeploying that cash the return on our
cash we took up a bit by investing in a
little bit longer life to assets and
making sure that we just were handling
the Treasury piece better we brought
back some shares which hadn't been done
too too well and you think moody is a
company which which rates debt I really
wondered why we were sitting with the
7.6 one piece of coupon that coupon on
our debt last year so I had noted that
interest rates had come down a little
bit thought it might be a good idea if
we refinanced so we actually did that
pretty successfully last year that was
great so we did all that stuff and the
stock price went from 44 dollars to 71
dollars in one year so were actually
less than that this was sort of three
quarters so that was pretty good that
was kind of neat how that all worked
market capitalisation went from 13.5
billion to 20 billion that was pretty
good that was that was a good first
couple of months so I asked my boss if I
could have a corporate development team
because
we probably ought to look outside the
base rating business and he said fine we
hired a guy from Citibank who's doing
that so we've built up a strategy side
in an M&A execution side we only have
about seven people now doing this our
Bravo's lured S&P up about 50 and we've
been able to do some deals we bought
economy dot-com which is a economic
consulting firm and we bought a business
in Israel we bought in a rating agency
in Israel and one in the Czech Republic
and then we've bought into a rating
agency in China which takes a long time
to get done so we're expanding the
worldwide scope which is good and I
hired some people got some people from
the outside good to have a strong
controller if you're the CFO and you're
not a CPA I would suggest that you get
the strongest nastiest meanest biggest
controller you can find so I did that
he's kind of dr. know we appreciate him
for that and former D&T partner so he's
very helpful to me I have an outside
person who does planning tax and
Treasury we have a very good staff at
Moody's we're able to do that the
Investor Relations person
formerly of Morgan Stanley has been
there for a few years the head of
internal audit joined us recently and
then we added the human resource
department for reasons that are unclear
to me we have a structured finance
lawyer from Australia who runs our human
resources group it works the structured
people respect her which is terrific
then we added corporate development and
real estate we had no real estate
function when I got their offices and
now close to 30 countries with no real
estate function so the transition from
small to large is really pretty hard to
manage and you've got to get that right
so we had to add some of these folks so
the point here you want some people from
inside you want some people from outside
you've got to get out of a mindset and
add some people who have more up-to-date
skills
so prior our prioritization and focus
what is the boss do and what do I do
ray McDaniel spends a lot of his time
talking to outside regulators talking to
Congress talking to our shareholders and
his focus is maybe 25 percent internal
my focus is about 25 percent external
spending time with shareholders but the
job is to free up ray so he can get out
and talk to people and the time
management challenge which you guys
probably don't think about quite as much
yet I get six internal meetings a day at
least one or two meetings with
shareholders I get 200 emails
today from around the world I get 10
plus vender cold calls a day do not have
your name on the website as a CFO
because you get calls from everyone all
the time really difficult investment
bankers I could spend my entire day just
talking to investment bankers that would
be an interesting use of use of my time
but not particularly profitable
I should add consultants to that group
as well so I could talk to these people
all day but it's not really a great use
of shareholder time constant meeting and
speaking requests which I generally
turned down but I've decided maybe I
should take this one so the solutions to
all that you have to learn to say no you
have to say we've got to focus on what
we have to do right now and you just
have to tell people I can't do it you
need a good assistant I don't do week
events during the week I have four kids
I do geometry and reading and complex
fractions when I go home in the evening
so I tend not to do too many outside
things and as I said I tend to try to
stick to our knitting which is a good
use of time now the latest room being a
female CFO is very interesting you can't
fix what you don't know so it's very
important to have open communication
lines and our previous CEO was not
really always one to communicate really
very well with everybody so I try very
hard to talk to people to know their
names to be approachable to be positive
act for ask for people's input and
people come up to me in the ladies room
and they say the darndest things you
know it's just amazing what you learn
just hanging out in the ladies room so I
find that to be a very good informal
channel for communications and we do
skip level meetings we walk around we go
to our international offices very very
important when you're dealing with
professionals who are very sophisticated
that you you actually get out and engage
them and talk to them otherwise very
hard to have their trust now despite all
this great stuff some days are just very
bad days so recently we had a bad day
April 26 I got on the earnings call
earnings call is a very high-pressure
event we announced this revenue growth
of 13% in the first quarter operating
income growth of 12% EPS growth of 26%
operating margin of 54% took the tax
rate down 150 basis points and we
announced that we had done a deal
you know for most companies you'd say
that's a pretty darn good first quarter
would love to have things like that
happen that's great
so our consensus estimate for those of
you who know how Wall Street analysts
work 49 sets we announced 49 cents okay
good enough that's fine the stock price
did that now the problem with this is
when you have a stock that has done
particularly well the expectations are
very high and you have some things show
up which are not always good things yeah
that guy show up so I was on vacation in
March and we're in Hawaii and my husband
calls me and he says look at this Kramer
is talking about Moody's and he was
throwing chairs and making mooing sounds
and doing all the stuff that Kramer does
and he was talking about how wonderful
Moody's was and how what a great
business model it was and this and that
and you know told everybody they should
go out and pile into moody stock which
momentum investors continue to do write
up about into that peak so this was not
the best of phenomenons for a company
that's largely institutionally held so
this is what the analysts said we're a
perennial surpriser
for the first time in 20 quarters we
didn't beat estimates in line is not
good enough momentum investors were
exiting and so one cent you know
although we did hit consensus one cent
4.5 billion dollar loss in value so this
job is not for the faint of heart and
sometimes I think back on my army
experience and I realized people don't
have live ammunition to shoot at us so
maybe it's not all that bad but this is
a this is a difficult situation to
manage through so we took a look at how
we've done over the last five years
still a tremendous stock still a lot of
growth potential in the company
absolutely nothing is actually changed
so I can't really tell you how we've
dealt with this because we're in between
earnings periods but if you tuned in on
June 6 to our Investor Day you'll see
what we've actually done about this so
it's been an interesting thing to manage
through now the tone at the top and
cultural responsibilities I thought this
is Stanford I can actually talk about
these things probably couldn't make this
presentation at Harvard but
it's it's a good presentation today on
days when skilling and Ken Lay were
found to be guilty which is interesting
a great job a huge responsibility being
CFO you can't forget who you work for it
you can't forget the clients the issuers
the intermediaries who are the
investment banks that we work with you
can't forget the employees because they
can all pick up and go work somewhere
else particularly being in Manhattan
being a jerk is a very 1990s sort of
thing being a big ego it's not going to
work these days you have to be pretty
humble because you have days when your
stock price tumbles like ours did and
you've got to be able to relate to your
investors and your employees and explain
to them what's happened and what you're
going to do about it
thank you still work burning bridges is
a very bad idea and as the public face
of your corporation you really have to
be conscious of how your image and the
image of your company is coming across
to shareholders and despite all that it
is really possible to have fun so in
2004 that thing was the Moody's annual
report cover if you look at it very
closely it's sort of a map of the world
but it was white
it was generic it was actually pretty
tedious so I also got the job of
redesigning the annual report so in 2005
we did this thing you know we try to do
kind of cheery California colors you
know sort of this matrix thing Sienna
earth tone pictures of Moody's you know
in the old days rating auto companies
and factories and then moving up to the
high-tech world of today so that was
very well received and mr. Buffett said
wow your annual report is really much
more colorful this year so I felt good
about that that was great not that any
of that matters but it's all objects so
Moody's a traditional company we do
stupid things we dish out ice cream for
the employees once a year but they
really really like it so we all put on
aprons and we dish ice cream and it's a
very sort of nice family kind of
atmosphere and people really enjoy it
very much so that tall guy in the middle
ray McDaniel is my boss Chris Mahoney
the guy on the right rates corporates so
if you want to send your complaints
please send them to Chris they're on
right and we have a terrific team so
it's a great job it's a lot of fun it's
a big responsibility but I feel thrilled
to have the opportunity that I that I do
so with that any questions from anybody
dad
to the trouble
that's an excellent question there are
some things you know that you could do
on the margin but given our
responsibility in the capital markets
we're very very careful about what we do
and we sort of have to play the hand
that we're dealt very difficult to
predict our business because it spikes
up at quarter end structure deals tend
to come at quarter end very hard to
predict where our earnings are going to
go which is part of the reason why we
have the challenge that we do managing
earnings is just not something that you
can do anymore
when I was at PepsiCo in the 90s we
watched GE would always put up nicely
escalating earnings that were handled
just perfectly coke would also do that
it was a great frustration at PepsiCo
about that but we have to we have to
sort of deal with what we have and it
can be a little lumpier than you would
like but part of what's happening with
reg FD is you can't talk to the analysts
about anything that's coming so you have
an ever-increasing disconnect with the
analysts and that's why you see some of
the choppiness in the market that you
might not have seen before it is a tough
thing to manage through sure competitive
environment there are five rated five
recognized rating agencies they're
called NRSROs nationally recognized
statistical rating organizations there's
Moody's there's SSP there's Fitch
there's AM best in Canada and Dominion
Securities in Canada the SEC decides who
is going to have that sort of
recognition from the SEC and they
control it so we have about 40% of the
market SPS 40% of the market Fitch has
about 15% and the others have the rest
and the competitive situation is
actually more dynamic than you would
think Fitch has really recently made
some big investments and they're now 20%
owned by Hearst which has made a big
investment in them as well
so the competitive situation while it's
relatively stable is one that it is a
competitive marketplace SP does some
things we won't they do we do some
things that we have greater focus and
structured than perhaps they might and
so it's sort of a
relatively reasonable competitive
dynamic SP is a division of mcgraw-hill
ticker
MHP and it's publicly traded Similac i
believe is also publicly traded and best
is a family owned company and Dominion
securities i think is private as well
well the first criteria that I use is I
think about what mr. Buffett says about
not doing anything dumb and that comes
first very difficult with the type of
multiple that we have to do acquisitions
that are not diluted and we look for
acquisitions that are close to our core
competencies in other words I always say
we don't want to go out and buy Krispy
Kreme
you know moodiest is a ratings agency we
have folks who are analytic we know the
capital markets we know the fixed income
markets we shouldn't stray probably too
far from there so look close to your
core the acquisitions of course have to
be financially attractive most
acquisitions brought to you by
investment bankers are by their very
nature overpriced with sort of overblown
growth views so you have to be really
careful about what you do in terms of
what we're doing we find returning value
to shareholders is a core part of what
we're doing with our capital strategy
and we found that cherry purchases are
generally given that we're a growth
company a better way to go than
dividends we have a rather modest
dividend and that's worked pretty well
for us
the one under bullying I think this is
actually quite a bit of opportunity
because we had what was effectively a
small company and it's grown very very
rapidly so the ability to do a better
job with IT for example to make sure
that all the people are sort of the
employees who are a bit finicky
financial services employees can tend to
be a bit finicky that they're all housed
in office to properly we can do that we
can work with the capital structure we
can do acquisitions any number of things
now given the size and the scope of the
company that we're able to do that are
really pretty pretty interesting
opportunities so I feel that there's
there's plenty of room to do do
interesting things and if you have any
acquisition ideas let me know
particularly a creative ones
yes I've thought about that quite a bit
the problem is the the role or the
challenge we have is the role we have in
the capital markets would the SEC for
example allow us to be acquired by an
LBO firm the cash flow characteristics
of the business are such that that might
be interesting the multiple right now is
probably prohibitively high to make us
an interesting acquisition for an LBO
player but the public company nature
I think ensures that we are running our
business at a standard that allows us to
rate other companies with a clear
conscience so I think our dealing well
with the public company rules and
restrictions these days sets a good
example for for others and I think
though I don't know it would be a bit of
a tough call for the regulator's to
allow Moody's with its size to be a
private company again not really sure we
haven't we haven't actively explored it
there's a beautiful thing called the
issuer pays model so we are we are
considered a publishing firm and we're
compared to media companies which is
interesting and amazing and perhaps a
different way to look at the market but
we are publishers so we're protected by
the First Amendment and what we're doing
is publishing opinion so if you issue
bonds if all you guys up there in the
sky decoration bonds you want to
differentiate and someday I hope you do
issue bonds you if you want to
differentiate your bonds from each other
so it's important for you to come to us
to get your bond rated so the capital
markets so the issuers pay us on average
four basis points to apply rating to to
their security and that's how we make
money now in the structure finance side
there are sliding scales in different
ways of thinking about fees it's a much
more structured fee view on the
corporate side than on the structured
side but basically it's a lot of deals
that we're eight four four basis points
that's basically how we make money
socks supposedly the you know greatest
bane to CFO human existence I don't
actually see it that way
it has allowed for the CFO to do things
that really perhaps might have been done
otherwise but it allows you sort of a a
real mantle to allow you to look at
everything within the company so my my
very ferocious controller has a Sox team
and we look at several hundred controls
within the company and we look at our
international controls and we look at
various things that we're doing to you
know sign offs on things and so on so I
think it actually does protect us quite
a bit from things going wrong it allows
us to escalate problems it's extremely
expensive to administer we spend about
four million dollars a year on Sox it's
coming off a little bit in the second
year the first year of implementation
was very very difficult it puts a lot of
strain on the organization but but if
you're sitting where we are and what you
do is rate other companies you better
get it right so I actually feel
relatively comfortable that that Sox is
in place and I think some of the
complaints about it frankly have been
just just a little bit overblown but for
smaller companies it is certainly much
more burdensome for public company is it
for the most part I think it has been a
relatively good addition
I'm actually trying to forget about it
but but but thank you for causing me to
I guess I should deal with it and work
through it I never took the tea group
class here either in Stanford I was an
army officer and army officers don't do
that kind of stuff okay what happened
that day the day before was the board
day and the board said to me what he
thinks gonna happen to the stock and you
know I talked to them about it and I had
sort of guessed wrong and our Goldman
advisors actually had a bit of a better
view so we're watching the stock you
know in pre trading we're looking at it
and the head of Investor Relations sits
next to me and he got a call and he said
to me it seems as though there's an
order in balance the stock is not going
to open today on time we're gonna be
delayed so there comes a moment where
you have to go upstairs and see your
boss and tell him that and that's a
tough time that's a very difficult time
and so we explained what that meant and
we had talked to the specialist and we
knew what was going to happen and we
talked about what was going to happen
next and it's difficult it's very
difficult then the way we do it we get
on our earnings call at 11:30 and it's
sort of like watching your own EKG you
can watch your stock price move as
you're talking about what you're doing
so we are quite pleased that actually
we've we hit bottom and then as we
talked it sort of moved back up so wow I
haven't destroyed any more shareholder
value that's good but it is it is very
challenging and fundamentally you know
our business is what the business was
and you know you have momentum money
moves quickly hedge fund money moves
quickly we don't have a lot of hedge
fund investors in our stock but on two
different days the market can have a
completely different response to the
financial outlook for any given company
it's it's tough to manage through so the
earnings call was actually quite if you
listen to the playback of it it was not
particularly dramatic and we we
continued on but it is a hard thing to
manage through you have to be very
careful that your emotions don't sort of
overcome your ability to think logically
on a day like that it is hard and in
that case having been an army officer
was really tremendous experience anybody
else
ratings industry in other countries is
perhaps not the pristine example setting
kind of thing that it might be you know
here in the US there are some more
political pressures perhaps in other
countries particularly developing
markets so we have to be very careful
when we buy into China for example that
we have a transfer of technology and our
values and our methodologies so that you
have a like rating process across the
world and it's very difficult to govern
that but we work very hard at it and we
have a chief credit officer Chris
Mahoney the guy you saw a dishing
ice-cream whose job it is to make sure
that all that works but it's a it's a
very difficult job to ensure standards
across the world our biggest problem
right now in China is while China has a
very active commercial paper market it
doesn't have a bond market yet the
reason why China does not have a bond
market near as we can tell is they can't
decide who's going to regulate it there
are about five different groups that
would like to regulate the bond market
in China so once that's settled we think
that it'll be clear as to what's going
to happen in China
I do differentiators hosting the next
year's
well I really have issue with your
duopoly view because Fitch has 15%
market share and with the billions of
dollars that Hearst is put in I think
they're quite a viable competitor also
in the insurance business and best is
really the leading practitioner in the
insurance space so they're very active
competitors there as well how do we
differentiate ourselves you've got to
get it right what we do requires that we
predict the probability of default in
fixed income securities so we do a lot
of tracking as to how accurate our
ratings are and our ratings are for the
most part extraordinarily accurate and
you have certain cases where you have
problems and Ronn for example but if you
have a fraudulent situation you're not
always going to be able to call that
right but material information has been
withheld from you and that's why there
was a criminal trial in that case well
it seems like the intermediaries the
investment banks whom we we appreciate
dearly because they do free Rd for us
they have an unending ability to think
up new products and we really do
appreciate that and that's a very very
good thing so the asset classes says he
saw keep changing you know cell phone
towers 50 year mortgage products the CDO
market you now have ceos of ceos in fact
now we're starting to see three rounds
of that so the level of complexity grows
dramatically and I personally don't have
the math skills to rate those
instruments so I stay a long way from
them but there is plenty of opportunity
and structured finance is growing
dramatically throughout the world also
in Europe the banks have held on to a
very important piece of the capital
markets which has not tracked the same
way that in the US market people would
go directly to the capital markets and
not be funded by banks the we believe
over time disintermediation will
continue in Europe and also in Asia
which is at an earlier
point in the cycle so that provides real
opportunity for us as well we have a
very rigorous ratings process which we
talked about with the SEC and Congress
all the time we have ratings committees
which are totally independent from
management for example I can have
nothing to do with the ratings process
there are a whole lot of code of conduct
things that go along with that if you're
rating a security you can't hold any of
the securities in your personal
portfolio if you're an analyst so we
keep very good separation and make sure
that the people who are doing the
ratings are not tainted in any way
beyond that the ratings teams monitor
all the activities going on with those
companies they possess a lot of very I
guess information which is not known to
the general market so it's a big
responsibility but they monitor the
companies they look at all the market
conditions and so on and from time to
time they'll make a different decision
on on companies but it's completely up
to them and they are influenced by no
one so the ratings analysts have a
tremendous amount of power yes
sure I was when I was CFO of us trust it
was a great divisional job but I thought
I've made it this far I'd like to step
up to the major leagues and be CFO of a
public company the recruiting firms tend
to find you and being a woman frankly or
being a more diverse candidate really
provides you with a lot of advantages
these days because you have much higher
visibility because there aren't too many
of us so it really is a very interesting
situation so the opportunity came along
was brought to me by a headhunter to
become CFO of Moody's and I just went
down and started the interviewing
process met all the former CFO is on the
board and I guess I got through that
because of my remarkable education yes
strategy well anything about the CFO
Wallace
generally the people who should be
thinking about controls day-to-day your
controller should be thinking about
controls I think about controls a lot
but that responsibility day-to-day is
managed by him I own it I can't delegate
it nor can my CEO or head of the Audit
Committee or the board but day-to-day in
terms of watching and making sure that
all the controls are being followed the
controller really handles that and our
head of internal audit who's also a very
ferocious sort of individual another
person you want to have at your side I
think that thinking about strategy and
capital allocation are really the heart
and soul of the job and I'm lucky to
have be in a position where I'm able to
do a lot of that which is which is
really very helpful the stepping stone
to the CEO job more CFOs are now
stepping up to the CEO job I think it's
tremendous training you have a very
strong partnership with the CEO but you
really have to think a lot about whether
you want to be the full outside face to
the corporation whether you want to
spend all the time required to really be
the public face of the company and there
there's a tremendous amount of pressure
and being in that top job so it's it's
really something each person has to
judge as to whether it's something
that's that's interesting
to each individual some people would
have you know the ambition and the
burning desire to do that and others are
kind of happy you know in the CFO role
quite honestly I haven't thought a lot
about that myself
well I I did recognize this fellow here
his name I don't know who used to work
max hi max max used to work for my
husband so he can tell you how much my
husband travels so the first trick is
being able to see him at all so we
obviously have to be very careful about
those sorts of things there there are
some interesting overlaps I think
overall though having having a spouse
who knows what you do who has the same
kind of education that you do well he
has a JD MBA from Wharton so not exactly
the same kind of education but a spouse
who can appreciate what you do and sort
of have some empathy for what you're
going through is really very very
helpful and once in a while I actually
you know get some free advice that I
don't have to pay for so it's a really
good thing
it all works pretty well
there there are two separate things
really we look at whether people are
following their socks controls does it
cause people to focus more appropriately
on on controls and to some extent
governance yes I think it does I think
it does I couldn't give you a better
measurement of that but yes I think it's
helpful good
I let the chief the head of the credit
committee really decide that but we do
have a view as if we rated ourselves you
know where it should be and my boss ray
McDaniel is a very strong view that we
should not look like we need the money
at any point in time our independence
has got to be absolutely assured so
we're very careful about that we have
people come in and tell us and this is
stunning to me we have people who come
in and tell us maybe you should really
leverage up the company and make
yourselves into a junk credit and it
makes your head kind of explode you know
it's sort of like have you guys not
looked at what we do for a living so
people give you you know the darndest
advice and you write down in your little
forum do not want to speak to these
bankers ever again but we do have a
sense of what that should be we have 300
million dollars of debt we have 160
million dollars of bank lines we have
the ability to draw another 700 million
dollars if I needed it under the private
placement that I have right now given
what we do raising money is not a
problem having banks not call you to
offer you money is actually a bigger
problem go ahead
sure I with with this August team
sitting here it has been tremendously
helpful and I thought the questions you
might ask if I had paid closer attention
while I was in the MBA program what
would I have paid more attention to
since you didn't answer that question
asked that question but I'll answer it
anyway would probably be accounting
accounting is not fun or not always sexy
but you didn't need to really know it in
my job it's very very important the most
important thing that I learned and I
think Stanford was very much ahead of
its time was teamwork and team work with
all different types of people and that's
a very very important skill you really
can't get anything done in a corporation
these days without the ability to handle
team work and be part of free-floating
work groups to deal with things like
what should Moody's do what kind of
acquisitions should we do what should we
do within the regulated business the non
regulated business and you work with all
different types of people and if you
can't be effective in a team setting you
really can't get anything done so I
think that was probably the main main
thing that I learned also the
connections that I made the people in my
class which are very strong bonds have
helped me quite a bit throughout my
career and it's been been tremendously
important and very helpful classes other
MBA programs that have twice as many
students don't have that sort of
connection going forward and will be
very helpful to you after you graduate
from here you may not realize it now but
it will be yes
that's probably one of the biggest
challenges that we face right now we're
very cognizant of the responsibility we
have in a situation like that you're
trying to balance two things which is
predicting the probability of default
and then also making sure that you don't
bounce the ratings around too much so
you have to have a view of continuity
but also correctness on the probability
of default so those two things have to
be balanced and that's the job of the
chief credit officer to make sure that
that that happens and so far I think you
know so good but it is it's a very
delicate balancing act and one that we
think about all day every day yes
the issue usually is what would we see
that could we're often asked that could
break the business model the regulatory
front is is relatively calm right now it
tends to spike up at various times but
the sec seems relatively happy with what
we do and how we do it we do see a
period of increased regulation of what
we do and probably the need for
self-regulation we think that probably
there will be sort of a sarbanes-oxley
type of regulation of rating agencies
which will be asked to perform under
going forward so we are looking very
carefully about increasing our
compliance efforts and things like that
making sure we have codes of conduct so
that within the US we're complying with
everything that they could come our way
and Europe there are a number of groups
which have an infinite number of letters
in their names which oversee what we do
there's a group called Caesar there's a
group called IOSCO which is the
international securities commissions
basically so we have to deal with those
agencies and make sure that we're in
compliance with what they want us to do
in their countries but generally it goes
relatively well we spend a tremendous
amount of time on dealing with that in
terms of you know what could hurt our
near-term outlook exogenous shocks which
are not planned for which cannot be
predicted if oil goes to you know 150
that's something which is obviously
would be very concerning but predictable
interest rate increases while it makes
our lives a little bit more difficult we
can see that coming so therefore we can
plan for it
somewhat sensitive at the credit cycle
but probably less so than people realize
we're internationally diversified right
now we have big businesses in Japan and
Europe they run counter-cyclical e to
each other
China's growing at 9% Europe's growing
at 2% u.s. is growing at 3% these are
rough integers but people are at
different places in the credit cycle and
as well as the funding cycle in
different countries so that offsets and
then we have a couple of businesses our
research business is a subscription
business 200 million dollars of revenue
a year which is not really related to
any of the above so that helps us and we
have the kmv business which is an
analytical business which also is not
particularly related to anything that we
do in terms of the credit cycle but
we're at a more difficult point here in
the credit cycle very difficult to
predict what the Fed is going to do
somewhat hard to tell if Ben Bernanke or
Maria Bartiromo is running the Fed
that's a little challenging for us so
you know we try to try to roll with the
punches of all those things and we have
quite a few economists in-house quite a
few so I guess that's basically it thank
you very much very good